[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es mal wieder ein One-Pot-Gericht,
also einen Eintopf,
mit Nudeln und Hackfleisch.
Das Ganze ist ziemlich schnell gemacht
und vor allem braucht ihr wirklich nur einen Topf.
Ihr habt ganz wenig Geschirr
und habt gleich ein leckeres Mittag- oder Abendessen.
Ich zeige euch mal die Zutaten.
Ich brauche dafür
400 Gramm Hackfleisch,
30 Gramm Olivenöl,
eine Zwiebel und zwei Knoblauchzehen,
50 Gramm Tomatenmark,
etwa 800 Milliliter Gemüse- oder Fleischbrühe,
200 Gramm Sahne,
400 Gramm Nudeln.
Hier habe ich noch Gewürze,
Chili,
Oregano,
Kreuzkümmel,
Paprika in Edelsüß
und ein Lorbeerblatt,
tiefgefrorene Erbsen
und Grana Padano oder Parmesan
und etwas Salz und Pfeffer.
Das Erste, was ich jetzt machen werde, ist
– also ich mache das Ganze immer ziemlich zeitsparend.
Deswegen schon mal den Topf erwärmen.
Olivenöl dazu geben.
Das Hackfleisch kann ich jetzt hier anbraten.
Okay, er war noch nicht heiß.
Er war noch nicht heiß.
Aber er wird jetzt gleich heiß.
Schön krümelig anbraten
und in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal die Zwiebel und die Knoblauchzehen fein hacken.
Ich habe zwei gesagt und nehme drei.
Aber ist egal, oder?
[Musik]
Dann gebe ich jetzt hier
die Zwiebel- und Knoblauchwürfel dazu
und brate sie einfach drei bis vier Minuten mit an.
[Musik]
Perfekt sieht das aus!
Jetzt kommt hier das Tomatenmark dazu,
wird kurz mit angebraten.
Und dann könnt ihr es direkt
mit der Gemüse- oder Fleischbrühe ablöschen.
Ich gebe jetzt hier erst mal nur 700 Milliliter rein,
weil ich einfach noch nicht weiß, wie viel
Flüssigkeit die Nudeln gleich aufsaugen werden.
Dann die Sahne dazu.
Die macht das Ganze schön cremig.
Hier gebe ich jetzt mal noch alle Gewürze dazu
und Salz und Pfeffer.
Beim Salz müsst ihr einfach ein bisschen aufpassen,
je nachdem, wie gewürzt
eure Gemüse- oder Fleischbrühe eben schon ist.
Also am besten wirklich abschmecken.
Und dann die Soße erst mal schön aufkochen lassen.
Das ist auch gleich passiert,
die kocht gleich.
So ein Stängel Rosmarin würde auch super dazu passen.
Ein bisschen Salz.
Es sieht immer nach so viel aus. Ich weiß.
Es ist aber nicht viel.
Es wird einfach nur fein gemahlen.
Und, sobald dann die Flüssigkeit kocht,
die Nudeln dazu geben.
Und das liebe ich einfach,
weil bei diesen One-Pot-Gerichten die Nudeln
in der Flüssigkeit gar werden
und dann einfach den kompletten Geschmack
einziehen und aufsaugen
und ich wirklich keine
Extraarbeit damit habe,
die Nudeln abzugießen, den Topf zu reinigen.
Und deswegen machen One-Pot-Gerichte Spaß.
Jetzt kommt hier der Deckel drauf.
Die Hitze schalte ich ein bisschen runter,
lasse das Ganze jetzt durchziehen und durchköcheln,
bis die Nudeln fast gar sind.
Und ich rühre immer mal wieder um,
damit einfach nichts auch anklebt.
Aber, wie gesagt, einfach Hitze runterstellen
und abwarten
und Käse reiben.
[Musik]
Guck. Ich habe extra das Glas weggestellt, damit man sieht,
dass mein Schneidebrett von Sturmwaffel ist.
Süß, oder?
Guck, Sturmi!
Perfekte Produktplatzierung.
[Musik]
Ta-daa!
Ich habe noch mal 200 Milliliter
Gemüsebrühe dazu.
Oh, ich muss den Herd wieder runterstellen.
Sonst brennt es an am Boden.
Und ich kann jetzt sogar
den Herd komplett ausmachen.
Denn im Gusseisentopf zieht einfach alles noch gut nach.
Jetzt hier noch den Käse dazu geben.
Der macht das Ganze schön sämig.
Yummy, yummy, yummy!
Und ich gebe zum Schluss noch die Erbsen dazu.
Da könnt ihr auch frische Erbsen nehmen.
Aber im TK habe ich eigentlich immer welche da.
Guckt mal. Allein schon die Farbe, oder?
Allein schon wegen der Farbe lohnt sich es.
Und wenn ihr jetzt andere Nudelsorten nehmt,
dann probiert es einfach mal aus mit der Wassermenge
oder mit der Brühe.
Denn, wie gesagt, ich nehme erst mal 200 ml weniger
und gucke dann, probiere mal.
Und wenn sie noch sehr hart sind,
auf jeden Fall noch dazu geben.
So. Deckel drauf.
Ich lasse noch mal fünf Minuten nachziehen
und dann wird probiert.
Okay, jetzt wird probiert.
Und ich finde, das sieht gut aus.
Findest du das auch?
>> JOSH: Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie es schmeckt.
Also es riecht schon richtig gut die ganze Zeit jetzt beim Dreh.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> JOSH: Ich muss sagen,
ich habe selber noch nie so einen One Pot gemacht.
>> SALLY: Was?!
>> JOSH: Ja, tatsächlich.
Ich mache mir so...
>> SALLY: Aber es geht doch voll schnell! Wir machen...
>> JOSH: Ja, das ist doch gut.
>> SALLY: O Gott! Wir machen so oft
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: nach Feierabend One-Pot-Gerichte.
>> JOSH: Mir war das nie so
– weißt du? Ich habe das nie so im Hinterkopf.
Und ich denke dann, ja,
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> JOSH: dann mache ich halt, wenn es schnell gehen muss,
Nudeln mit einer kleinen Beilage oder...
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Aber eigentlich könnte ich auch das mal...
>> SALLY: Ja, Eintopf, nur ein Topf.
>> JOSH: Ich probiere das mal aus, das Rezept.
Ich probiere es auf jeden Fall aus.
>> SALLY: Okay, probiere es mal.
Okay, vielleicht, nachdem du probiert hast.
>> JOSH: Also danach.
Aber ich bin sicher, es schmeckt.
>> SALLY: Also ich glaube, ich schmecke jetzt schon raus,
dass es zu wenig Chili ist für meine Verhältnisse.
Aber ich koche immer...
>> JOSH: Es muss nicht immer scharf sein.
>> SALLY: Ja. Ich komme immer mit wenig Chili
oder gar nicht mehr.
>> JOSH: Ja, würze du dir nach und ich glaube,
>> SALLY: Wegen den Kindern.
>> JOSH: für uns ist das ganz okay so.
Weil da ist ja schon auch dann
einiges an Pfeffer immer drin so. Das ist dann...
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen.
Oh, was auch gut gepasst hätte, wären Champignons.
>> JOSH: Hm. Ja.
>> SALLY: Mmh! Wenn ihr noch Champignons habt,
macht noch Champignons rein.
>> JOSH: Das mache ich dann für mich rein.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Richtig lecker!
>> SALLY: Ich auch nächstes Mal.
>> JOSH: Richtig schön herzhaft.
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> JOSH: Auch vielleicht an so einem
ein bisschen kälteren Tag einfach
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: ein schnelles Gericht,
was einfach richtig satt macht.
Cool!
>> SALLY: Und so cremig, gell?
>> JOSH: Hm. Oh, voll! Das finde ich genial.
>> SALLY: Finde ich auch.
>> JOSH: Erinnert so ein bisschen an Käse-Makkaroni,
so ein bisschen, nicht? So was.
>> SALLY: Ja. Oh, Mac and Cheese!
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Sollen wir mal Mac and Cheese machen?
>> JOSH: Hm. Au ja!
>> SALLY: So aus – keine Ahnung – vier Zutaten
Mac and Cheese einfach?
>> JOSH: Au ja!
>> SALLY: Und das Rezept war jetzt
– also ich meine, wir filmen hier nebenher,
ich mache noch sauber.
>> JOSH: Genau.
>> SALLY: Aber innerhalb von
zehn Minuten hat man alles im Topf
und dann wartet man noch mal zehn, fünfzehn Minuten
und alles ist fertig.
>> JOSH: Wirklich superschnell.
>> SALLY: Schon gut.
Ich würde jetzt dazu einfach nur noch einen Salat machen.
>> JOSH: Hm. Ist auch gut, so ein bisschen was Frisches.
>> SALLY: Ja, was Frisches.
Und dann hat man einfach ein schönes Abendessen
oder Mittagessen.
>> JOSH: Auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Bei uns jetzt Mittagessen.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und da freuen wir uns jetzt alle drauf.
Also...
Und das würde auch super,
finde ich, mit veganem Hack funktionieren.
>> JOSH: Mit Sicherheit. Mit Sicherheit.
Weil die Gewürze sind so laut. Also das ist...
>> SALLY: Ja, genau. Man kann es super auch veganisieren.
Vegane Sahne oder Kokosmilch zum Beispiel
>> JOSH: Ja, genau.
>> SALLY: und dann einfach veganes Hack.
Und dann habt ihr auch ein perfektes veganes Gericht.
Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Wir setzen uns jetzt mit den anderen an den Tisch.
Und falls ihr weitere einfache Rezepte sehen wollt
oder Rezeptwünsche habt,
schreibt es einfach in die Kommentare.
Vielleicht will ja der Josh mal mit mir kochen.
>> JOSH: Sollen wir das mal probieren?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Ich wäre dabei.
>> SALLY: Soll Murat dann hinter die Kamera?
>> JOSH: Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das verantworten kann.
>> SALLY: Vielleicht nicht.
Ich erinnere mich an unscharfe Sequenzen
aus meiner Vergangenheit.
>> JOSH: In welchem...
>> SALLY: Tschau!
>> JOSH: Tschau!
Also dann
>> SALLY: Tschau!
>> JOSH: macht es gern nach.
>> SALLY: Das Rezept gibt es auf sallys-blog.de
oder in meiner kostenlosen App,
in der Sallys Welt App.
Und da könnt ihr die Zutaten sogar umrechnen lassen,
alles ganz digital.
Ihr müsst nicht mitdenken,
einfach rechnen lassen.
Und die Einkaufsliste erstellen könnt ihr auch.
Und ihr könnt sogar die Einkaufsliste erstellen,
abhaken, was ihr schon zu Hause habt,
und dann an jemanden schicken zum Einkaufen.
>> JOSH: Und die Videos
>> SALLY: Und die Videos.
>> JOSH: sind direkt dabei.
[Musik]